IT IN FOR THE BLUE TO BE THE CHK
RIGHT SUED.
GETS AROUND.
DUMPS
>> WERE TALKING
ABOUT THEY W W
RECOVERS.
SILLINGER SET UP IN FRONT.
TIED UP WITH MAYFIELD.
THE PUCKK DOBSON.
TO,
SOME EMOTION.
AND HERE'S A
NELSON GETS TURNED AROUND.
AND HE SCORES!
ON THE
ADVANTAGE HERE.
THEY GET THE PUCK IN EASILY.
OF IT'S A
HELD IN.
COMING FOR HIGH.
THEY GET LOST.
THE PENALTY
KILLING.
PENALTY KILLERS HAVE
THE PUCK.
WORK OFFENSE.
A POWER MOVE.
LEFT HAND COMES OFF HIS STICK.
HE A SCORING CHANCE HERE FOR THE
ISLANDERS AND THEY'RE UP 2-0
ZLAMUCK UP AND OUT OF
THE ZONE.
JOSH BAILEYY SCORES!
BLUE JACKETS.
BUT WATCH THE PRESSURE FROM THE
ISLANDERS.
THEY'RE ALL OVER THEM.
EVERY TIME YOU LOOK UP,
U LANDER STUD! CHANCES TO.
AND THE ISLANDERS BUZZING IN  O.
YOU CAN SEEINE.
TWO-ON-ONE AS THEY COME ACROSS
THE LINE.
CENTERS AND THE WEAKNESS.
THEY JUMP UP.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL PA GREEN.
FOR LALA ICE.
THE ISLANDERS DEFENDIDI JOB TO
AND I.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A PLEASURE.